how did achieve you come to this project
well I Alfonso first came to see me
before he had finished the script he was
in the middle of it and he had a pretty
good idea of the story because when he
came to see me we sat down in a you know
on a couple of sofas and I just remember
him talking through the story for 45
minutes with me and even then it was
breathtaking I remember coming out of
the meeting feeling excited you know
just just having heard the story really
and you know at that stage he was still
thinking it was going to be a very
simple and very quick and easy film to
make but you know we we were soon to
discover otherwise in fact i joined i
was think the second or third animator
to join the previous team won his
Alfonzo sailors in a small room with an
animator I was supervising another
project in parallel and I was sort of
seeing what they were doing and getting
quite excited about it and thinking in
the back of our mind I want to get on
that project when I finished the one I
was supervising that was in early 2010 a
long time again and for me I my
backgrounds in editing but I had also
add some visual effects editing and so
and I'd indeed had worked for Alfonso as
visual effects editor on children of men
I think for this particular project
Alfonso realized you know that his
co-editor was going to have to be
somebody who not only understood editing
and there are the workings of editing
but also the background to to visual
effects and I happen to know Tim as well
which which helped and so yeah off on to
call me at home and I went through it
and yeah he said to me also it's going
to be a six-week shoot
it's going to be a skeleton crew it's
going to be in black and white it's
gonna be so cool man there was three
main challenges to it really there was
the fact that it was set in space which
it's not very far away but it's not a
location you can go and film in easily
and although our fonso did consider it
it you know it's set in zero gravity it
has incredibly long shots in it you know
Alfonso was pushing the technique he
developed on earlier films to to use the
long roaming developing shots as a
technique for storytelling and those
those you know were the immediate
challenges and I think you'll see see
all of them in this and yeah you know
they those challenges didn't just add
together they actually multiplied each
other particularly the long shots it
just added complexity to everything else
that you did in the movie and you know
that was part of what we didn't realize
just how challenging it was going to be
at the beginning the fact that it was
set in space was clear from the
beginning and Alfonso Alfonso's initial
idea was he wanted to suspend the actors
in full space suits from wires in front
of a partial build of the Hubble you
know on on a stage against green screen
and we would sort of extend the Hubble
and put the earth in the background but
you know it's so set creating space
around them fairly straight forwards
what we started to learn from this
though as we started to work out how we
were going to make it was just how
complicated zero gravity was going to be
and how much everything is different
when you've got actors upside down and
and how hard that was going to be to
shoot and we also started to realize
something that Alfonso hadn't told us
fully to begin with was just the extent
to which he was going to do the long
shots it wasn't even children of men
long shots it was going well beyond that
in fact just to give everyone an idea
the movie you know typical movies these
days have two thousand shots in this had
about 350 the opening shot is nearly 30
minutes long and and seventy percent of
the movie 70
to the movie is made up of 17 shots
that's you know so it's a it's not just
one opening shot is a lot of long shots